this is
so bad it's so bad
so that's the cg car that's a cg car wow
it's not cg right well
it's kind of cg kind of my favorite kind
of cg
welcome back to another wonderful
episode of visual effects artists react
we have some really awesome clips for
you guys today wren
how's it going
hot dog
gonna be looking at some old movies some
bike scenes that make you scratch your
head a little bit but more so we're just
gonna have a good time and i hope you do
too so let's get into it
[Music]
so the new lord of the rings movie has
just dropped
well okay not a movie it's a show and
the show isn't out yet it's coming out
in september i believe
the intro to the show just dropped and
it's a cg wonder fest look at all these
amazing renders this that looks
excellent like all the little like
little particles sparky details coming
off catching the light in great ways
the water though i think the resolution
on the simulation for the water could be
better
i know where you're going with this
friend yeah i think i think you both
know where i'm going
i know where you're going with this none
of that cg actually take it back there's
a little bit of cg but the vast majority
of that was all
real right that is correct the water is
real
the water the smoke is real that's real
metal
good good god
is that 100 real even the amazon logo
well
they actually poured real molten metal
down it and poured real water across it
with a bunch of steam and and all of
that that's cool and they had a robot
arm holding a phantom flex 4k to be able
to quickly go
to get those sort of sweet slow-motion
shots and that's why it looks cg this is
actually how they film a lot of food by
the way with the same like robot
controlled phantom cameras i do think
some of the water was comfortable no i
don't think so i think the water is real
no i think it's real for a lot of i
think it's comped a little bit in a few
of the shots it's i'm not quite sure
exactly what they're doing but like my
digital artifacts like detector is going
off somehow they could have totally just
done that in two separate passes they
have a robot arm that can repeat the
same move
over and over and over again so in that
situation maybe they had something where
they have the metal it's still kind of
hot they do their take for the exposure
of the metal they'd probably have to
bring up the exposure a little bit but
then the water would be too bright so
they do another pass where they have the
water go over it with the exposure
slightly lower
and then they're just kind of combining
the two shots in post this is
speculation we do not know i you know i
think it's totally reasonable you can if
you have a motion control rig you can
totally blend some shots like and
there's probably a little bit of that
going on especially with the n1 with the
logo reveal oh there's a cd like you can
see how there's smoke yeah that's going
in two opposite directions over itself
it's lcg smoke that's cd smoke yeah
that's definitely definitely a lot of cg
smoke at least in that transition we
always say that the best looking visual
effects shots are the ones that combine
practical with cg because purely cg can
sometimes look pretty good but purely
practical usually isn't quite enough and
i think what they found here is that
they have this really sweet transition
here and it's not quite working unless
they add in some of that smoke in fact
you can totally see it fade out right
there in the middle as the camera's
pulling back it looks
really good it looks amazing but it goes
back to like the media always
loves to say something is not using any
cg and that's rarely rarely ever the
case even in this
example where the headline is straight
up they did it all practically and it's
it's true
but they did supplement it with
additional vfx at the end of the day
it's a super dope looking shot and it
makes me want to do an entire themed
episode around show intros so leave a
comment down below with intros you'd
like us to look at that's a good one
that's a good one
so speaking of stuff done in camera
completely practically let's take a look
at this shot real quick wait wait wait
wait wait just sorry before you play you
remember the stump and react episode
where we watched steven seagal and mike
tyson fight
i already know what the shot this is
this is right before that happens
that is a really funny fight scene yeah
same movie this is literally just before
it happens
[Music]
wait a second
oh boy yeah
this face comes out of the helmet
because maybe the audience needs to
understand that steven seagal is the one
who's driving up to the
the arms deal that's happening this is
so bad it's so bad why why is it bad
though that's the question so the vfx
artists did this shot we're sorry you
had to do this shot we know that someone
told you that you need to put steven
seagal's face in this helmet and you're
like that doesn't make any sense you
won't be able to see his face like you
can't see the guys facing the helmet
already right and they gave you probably
like a stock photo
and you went to town he did your best
but like so through the shot we can see
that there's no parallax change on his
face so it is definitely just a 2d image
and likely literally just a jpeg it
literally looks like it's a sticker
stuck on top of his face as opposed to
any sort of depth inside you can see
that the skin his skin in the helmet is
brighter than the skin on his arm in
direct sunlight physically you wouldn't
be able to see a face like that through
the helmet so the moment that's what
you're trying to do is the moment the
shot breaks also i just realized the
helmet is like
back
like his face is jutting out the front
of the helmet because the padding goes
down your temple like it's right next to
your eyes and yet we can see his side
burns and ear you can see his ear his
face is looking the sizes this is what
i'm saying his head is very small
[Laughter]
that's too big for him
how does he do this like how does he he
got hired he got paid a boatload because
steven seagal doesn't lose in his fights
it's like part of his contract but
they're like we're in china you can't
sue us and so he loses in his fight here
but you can clearly tell they filmed
with someone else that wasn't steven
segolf at the end of his fight scene
they'll be like great and then the fight
ends
and then he leaves seven like all right
get the double out beat his ass
that's exactly how it went
yeah that's exactly how it went
[ __ ] you drink pit
all right so you got an actor and you
have a motorcycle and you want to
pretend that an actor's riding a
motorcycle
we have some top-notch ilm effects here
this is the new james bond movie but
there's a lot of really great visual
effects that is
very well done and deceptive for most of
the stuff it's like half cg and it's
like the weirdest stuff that's cg
that's so cool look at that so that's
the cg car that's a cg car wow it looks
great the bump right when it bumps is
the only time it looks a little fake so
you see how there's direct sunlight that
is being covered by shadow like the soft
shadow so that soft shadow wouldn't be
darkening direct sunlight like that it
just would not look like that but it's
on the bottom of the frame you're not
even looking at that you're looking at
the car but that weird kind of softness
of that shadow and how it's not
interacting correctly with the ground
that's what triggers my cg alarm when i
look at it closely but
beyond that like the motion's great and
the rendering's really solid on the car
itself but i think this entire shot is
cg ilm basically
they
do photo scans of every location they're
going through they take cars with an
array of red cameras and just like roll
them up and down the streets to get
hdris for every single area they're
filming in
and you know you look at that shot there
it's like the motion of the car it's
like obviously you don't want to do that
with a real person there so either a do
you
run the car over it and put a cg person
in or do you put a real person in and
put a cg car there but then if
if the car is going to be cg then you
don't want to film a practical shot for
it really because who knows what the
movement's going to end up looking like
so
i think what we're seeing here is a
photo scan of the actual road and the
bridge there and the background where
you're seeing is probably just a 2d
plate projected onto some geometry
inside of nuke for the background and
then a cg daniel craig and a cg car
so most of the shot we're seeing here is
completely rendered
whoa wow
wait hold up
so i think i remember seeing something
about this motorcycle jump being an
actual real stunt it's totally real oh
sick
did they paint out the ramp yes so there
was a more clearly built ramp basically
that was there and they just replaced
the ramp with
the stonework gotcha and then obviously
that makes sense to me then because it's
like you wouldn't be able to actually do
a proper jump like this on stone yeah
and feeling a little gta i i think it
speaks to the idea that if something
feels impossible i think we just tend to
assume that it is impossible and
therefore faked i think the reason for
me it felt cg or like i questioned it
was honestly the camera angle so we're
watching this whole motorcycle sequence
and we're doing face replacements
already we're getting like shots right
close up to the camera
and in this shot it was like this very
like wide
slow moving like cgs movement
of this huge stunt when like we already
know they have the tools available to
like fully replace the head fully
replace the whole area it's like why not
get something that
like gets a little more in your face or
with the action a little more so that
way it doesn't make us immediately go
well
they could have faked that it's a
fantastic stunt like it really is at the
level you expect you know when you watch
a film like this
so how many of these sheep do you think
are real oh no
no
the cars in a lot of these shots are
just 100 cg because we got really good
cg cars a while ago and they're just
getting better every year they replaced
the roads and basically every shot of
the car is driving really because
they were doing multiple takes and so
they're getting skid marks everywhere
and so basically basically every shot of
the cars driving anywhere is cg road
it's a cg road
man they're doing the glasses properly
we talked about how they're just like
images tracked in on the matrix train
but here they're actually catching light
properly yep they get actual refraction
is happening yeah like that's the
three-dimensional object yeah even
though glass is thin
it's still three-dimensional
you know there's still depth to it and
when a crack happens you need to do more
than just take glass shatter o1.jpeg
and set it to screen mode
[Laughter]
what i'm seeing here the reason why it's
3d is that you have essentially an
actual
strip that is perpendicular to the
window and is sitting inside the window
and that strip itself is reflecting
light from the sun into the camera it's
actually catching the highlights
differently than just a 2d image tracked
in which you can clearly see in the
matrix resurrections there's a really
good example on the far left the
farthest left bullet hole there's a
circular strip and if you look the part
that the strip that's kind of facing us
is like wide and white you can see the
line really wide then as the strip comes
around and it becomes edge on to us it
turns into a tiny little thin line cause
that's exactly so those strips you know
they're perpendicular to the window
they're inside the window those strips
can reflect light but when you look at
them side they're now perfectly flat you
can't see them and we're like you're
totally right you're different you
actually have perspective in your in
your cracks oh can i tell you my the one
last fun fact about the whole thing no
moving on
enjoy speaking of the show we try to
stick to things that we know we know
visual effects we know some filmmaking
we got some ideas of how stunts work to
some degree right so we took a look at
the book of boba fett and we definitely
went out of our lane to uh talk about
our opinions
about things that weren't vfx really did
is this something
that robert rodriguez
[ __ ] up so if you want to see some of
those hot takes it's on the website
since we don't want to make anybody sad
on youtube so if you want to check it
out you can check it out there
did you guys see the movie hook back in
the day i love hook hook is great hook
is an amazing movie everybody's like
hook is sewage's worst movie and it's
like what what
says that it's fantastic i really want
better people
bitter people better people it's about
robin williams becoming a child or
yeah
this movie all i remember fantastic set
design great cast cool story lots of fun
zany action scenes that as a child i was
i was like i'm going to burger king and
i'm going to get all these hook toys so
in the movie robin williams plays peter
pan and he's lost his imagination he's
lost his happy thoughts so he loses his
ability to fly until this point in the
movie when he does get those happy
thoughts back and he takes off into the
sky and flies to the island
[Music]
flying across the clouds look at his
shadow on those clouds i don't know how
the red clouds
oh that looks nice oh my god that matte
painting looks so good that's not cg
right well it's kind of cg kind of my
favorite kind of cg basically the matte
painting artist you used to ghee i'm
just once i'm actually trying to say a
name correctly you say uh
but he's the matte painting artist on
this and he made a giant piece of
artwork of the island here but what they
did was something new in visual effects
remember this is 1991. they projection
mapped that onto 3d geometry so that
they could do a 3d camera move cool
and that's like i love projection
mapping and projection mapping is the
idea of like you have an image from a
projector right it's this 2d image that
just goes outwards and hits whatever you
see and then from there you can then
move and see it from different
perspectives you know those chalk
drawings you see that are only really
images from a certain perspective that
is essentially projection mapping and so
what they're doing here is they have
this incredible artwork that's done and
they're just projecting that onto
rudimentary geometry so that as the
camera moves you get a certain amount of
parallax within the image so it becomes
more 3d looking you know i hope that
someone
has that matte painting in their home
and it's not just sitting in a closet
gathering dust because seeing like how
big that thing is and how vibrant it
looks it's just like
who wouldn't want to look at that every
day now i got that info from ian again
vfx befores and afters amazing resource
but the thing that i found even more
interesting than that
were the clouds yeah the clubs look
really good the clouds are amazingly
well done the clouds are real practical
elements shot with go motion what is go
motion we've talked about it before it
is stop motion but every time they hit
the shutter button to take the
stop-motion photo the rig actually moves
a little bit to get the motion blur stop
motion famously lacks motion blur but go
motion hence the go they're recording
the shots as it moves so we're getting
the clouds which are just big cotton
balls
cotton balls tons and tons of passes of
cotton balls with the the go motion rig
going on but the thing that blew my mind
was the cg shadow of robin williams on
the clouds you can see the shadow
hitting this cloud and then dipping down
to the cloud below and then rising back
up to the cloud above that i wonder if
that's the blue screen element that's
also projection mapped onto geometry and
they're just doing noise distortion on
the geometry to match the clouds
that would be the way i would try to do
it that'd be pretty effective like
they're already they already got their
pc loaded up with some 3d models that's
like
they just press a button and it's done
this this is an example of a shot that
took a tremendous amount of attention to
detail
having that shadow and the real cotton
clouds there is really what brings the
shot together and makes it feel real as
you're watching it hey pro tip for all
you people with small screens if you
scroll down there's a subscribe button
maybe you missed it just letting you
know look i don't care if you subscribe
i don't care if you're dinging that bell
just if you like the show come back we
have another episode next saturday we
have never missed the weekend every
saturday since the show started actually
the first episode went up and then we
missed one weekend and then from that
point on we never missed because we
needed a week to kind of realize wait a
minute
yeah this is a thing let's keep doing it
so we needed a way to invent our most
popular show real quick
oh boy zach zach zach hold on zach
before you stop the video remember
tomorrow we also have another awesome
video coming out so check back on our
channel then yeah see you then zach
[Laughter]